Imagine a world where anything you can
think of can become a visual reality.
A Watermelon Pie? We got it. A Cactus ghost?
Got it. Hunter S Thompson as
the president? We got that too.
For the last several days I’ve been obsessed with
an AI imagine generator called “Midjourney.” You
put in a prompt like “the perfect cloud” and it
spits out some results. Sometime the results are
awful, sometimes they’re bizarrely terrifying,
but just as many times they’re incredible.
Here’s a movie camera by Pablo Piccaso.
Infinite Cabbage. / A bathroom designed by
MC Escher. / A person made entirely out of
cheese. / Deluxe beans. / A strip mall
painted by monet. / Dune directed by Wes
Anderson. / A bubble gum farm. / “Family Dinner”
by David Lynch / A Symbol for Bliss / Chicken
Nuggets at a michelin star restaurant. /
Cotton Candy grapes. / Twin Peaks drawn by
a child. / A potted tongue plant.
/ Pills by Gucci
I’ve spent hours surfing through what is
essentially humanity’s collective imagination
remixed by my random ideas and a powerful
Artificial intelligence. It’s addicting
and fascinating. Every idea is like a gamble,
you don’t know if it’s going to spit out
something amazing or just a pile of trash.
sorry, a box of trash by Van Gogh
But it’s as terrifying as it is fascinating.
As this technology improves, (which it already
is; DALL-E 2 Google’s AI image generator is
much more powerful than Midjourney) What will
it mean for art, images, imagination? What is
a world where anything we imagine can become a
reality? What if we put everything on a bagel?
That Funny Feeling
There’s a new feeling I’ve been feeling
occasionally in recent years. It’s hard
to describe, deeply personal, overwhelming,
fractal, uncomfortable, and yet enticing and
awe-inspiring. For a while I wasn’t sure what
it was. I wasn’t sure where it was coming from,
or if anyone else was experiencing
what I was occasionally feeling.
And then- in 2020, I started noticing some
artists starting to depict the feeling.
The first person who really put
a finger on a part of the feeling
was Bo Burnham with his Comedy Special Inside:
That funny feeling.
But another recent work- that captures
the feeling in an even more fundamental
way I think is the incredible, hypermodern,
maximalist film Everything Everywhere All At Once.
It’s easy to get bogged down in the technical
elements of “multiverses” and how they work
either as a storytelling device, or as an actual
theory for our own cosmos. But what I’m most
interested in about the multiverse, as it’s used
in Everything Everywhere all at once, is as a
metaphor for our own world and our own experience.
And for in a certain sense, the experience of:
Title: “The Internet”
I love the internet. For someone who’s always
loved learning about new and novel things,
who has a kind of insatiable curiosity, and could
spend all my time just endlessly exploring and
learning about what’s out there if I didn’t have
to also do other things like socialize, pay rent,
and eat: the internet has been a garden of
endless wonder, delight and possibility.
The internet has an inexhaustible variety
of cool stuff, tons of fascinating people
and ideas to discover. The internet is why I’m
able to have such a cool and interesting job.
But it’s also a double edged sword. Even when
it’s pointed towards what on the surface feels
like productive learning, and not just
mindless entertainment, when given the
option to fulfill endless curiosity, there comes
a tipping point, a crossing of the bell curve.
Here’s the thing: We don’t need an actual
multiverse to put cracks in the clay pot
of our mind when we already have devices for
careening through the endless imaginations of
the multitudes, when we exist in an environment
where you can encounter the personal stories and
experiences from people on every continent,
all who are living their own unique life in
just a few minutes, all from the comfort
of your own toilet. When more interesting
ideas and concepts, and people and places can fly
by in the space of one 30 minute Tik Tok binge
then some of our ancestors experienced in the
entirety of their localized illiterate lives.
The internet, for those who are inspired to spend
lot of time on it and use it in a certain way,
for those who envelope themselves in it’s
self-referential world of constantly evolving
novelty and imagery, will inevitably have a
profound effect on the way you see the world.
The Overview Effect
What is the result of
the headlong dive through novel ideas and imagery?
Many Astronauts, upon seeing earth
for the first time from space,
spinning by below them report something
that has been dubbed “The Overview Effect”
“It is the experience of seeing
first-hand the reality of the Earth
in space, which is immediately understood to be a
tiny, fragile ball of life, "hanging in the void",
shielded and nourished by a paper-thin atmosphere.
These astronauts are noting a
difficult-to-describe shift in their psyche
as a result of their extreme shift in physical
perspective. And while I don’t think the effect
of being “very online” is same as The Overview
Effect that astronauts experience, I do think
there’s an analogous effect that can happen from
consuming the amount of information many of us
now do. Seeing so much of the world so quickly can
trigger a sort of psychological paradigm shift.
The shift isn’t coming from being exposed to a new
idea of perspective that forces you to reassess
your own, the shift comes from the shear amount
of perspectives and ideas that we’re exposed to.
The shift and the feeling of this shift can
contain some positives, but it isn’t all good.
I think for most people the Digital Overview
Effect is a gradual and pervasive accumulation,
slowly building up as we swim through a world
of thoughts, ideas, concepts and emotions,
all projected at us through images, text, and
video, one after another in an endless parade.
Each new idea can pull you in a different
direction, and there’s a certain point where
everything, the infinite possibility starts to
look and feel like nothingness, at at that point,
the entire thing collapses on itself. Sincerity
is long gone, but irony has also died.
//
For me Everything Everywhere All at once
is one of the first true post-internet
films. It’s not just about the internet,
it doesn’t just comment one the internet,
but fully embraces it in all it’s absurdist,
chaotic glory. The maximalist excess
and the complete tonal whiplash from one
moment to the next, captures the unhinged,
unfiltered anarchy of using the internet in a way
that nothing else I’ve ever consumed ever has.
This is a movie for people who have found
themselves blinking sleep out of their eyes
with 50 tabs open at 2am, which I suspect
is many more of us than we openly admit.
In an interview with Slashfilm, Daniel
Scheinert, one of the movie’s directors said:
“We've talked a lot about what it's
like to have grown up with the internet,
and how that exacerbated the typical generational
divide, and what it feels like for everyone,
no matter old you are, to live right now with the
internet. So, that's one of the key metaphors,
was just like, we wanted the maximalism of
the movie to connect with what it's like to
scroll through an infinite amount of stuff,
which is something we're all doing too much.”
Most media that tries to comment on the internet,
comments on the “content” of the internet, or one
small element that it wants to critique, but it
doesn’t comment on the message that comes from the
medium of the internet. The way the most absurd
or inane things you’ve ever seen coexist in the
immediate context of tragedy and your family and
friends. Everything Everywhere All At Once does.
It’s silly and stupid and choatic
because, well. Welcome to the Internet.
Jobu Tupaki is a child of the internet,
raised in and by the chaos of the multiverse,
cast unknowingly by her parents, without training
wheels, into the void. She doesn’t have the
skills to cope, and neither do many of the real
teenagers who are growing up on the internet now.
Evelyn first tries to resist, and then
tries to understand, but realizes that
she too is not equipped to handle the
onslaught of experiencing the internet head on.
How do we handle this situation?
How do we stare head on into the
void? Maybe you haven’t experience what I’m
talking about, maybe you don’t know what I mean.
Maybe you’ve been able to venture into this Brave
New World we’re living in relatively untouched,
but even if you haven’t I would argue that you
have. Our world is being shaped and formed by
people who have gone in and haven’t come
out unscathed, while my parents generation
and even mine got to grow up with the internet as
something that you still went to as box to log on
to, current generations are growing up with it as
an omnipresent extension of themselves. They grow
up in a technological world increasing dominated
by the internet, where it’s intertwined with their
education, social lives, and careers,
and where it increasingly takes a bold
and defiant individual to take a step
away, much less disconnect entirely.
And it’s not slowing down. While
the adults in power are just now
becoming aware of the issues that began rearing
their heads in a decade ago, the next decade
holds even more astonishing wonders and terrors,
waiting for us to embrace them with open arms.
It might sound from all this that I
think it’s a very hopeless situation.
But I don’t really think that, or at least I
don’t feel hopeless, and neither does Everything
Everywhere All at Once, which ultimately
affirms a quiet acceptance of a life that openly
acknowledges the infinite chaos and possibility,
but quietly ignores it and makes the choice to
value more immediate and personal things.
And in some sense while chaos reigns on a
planetary scale, it is possible I think for an
individual to find a better, healthier way to
engage with this Brave New World, and while that
doesn’t fix the problem as a whole, if we can’t
figure out how to engage with these things
in a healthy way as individuals, we’ll never
figure out how to do it as communities.
And to engage with this world in a healthier way,
you’ll have to understand what doesn’t matter.
Because the internet is a place
where everything matters all at once
all the time. But the real word, the
life you’re living, is one where you can
only pay attention to a few thing in one
place, at a time. And giving your time and
attention to a few things that do matter
means looking an almost infinite world of
possibility constantly vying for you attention
and boldly proclaiming that it doesn’t matter.
There’s a quote from Marshall McLuhan that gives
me hope when thinking about these kinds of issues,
so I’ll leave you with that:
“There is no inevitability, so long as there is
a willingness to contemplate what is happening.”